une femme policier très grièvement
blessé c'est le dernier rebondissement à
jérusalem d'une affaire de fouilles
archéologiques commencé l'année dernière
autour de la vieille ville
les activistes religieux ultraorthodoxes
affirmant que ces fouilles profane les
tombeaux des anciens rois de juger de
judée pardon situé selon re à l'endroit
exact où ont lieu les travaux est la
violence de ces orthodoxe qui
n'acceptent pas même de reconnaître
l'état d'israël qui ne doit son le que
revivre à la fin des temps est bien
connu et redouté même de la police de
jérusalem
notre correspondant didier pennes vient
chez rim
est ce encore le cas recul frappe dox de
jérusalem cette semaine dans cette
atmosphère d'émeutes
la police israélienne a réagi avec une
violence extrême après avoir eu
plusieurs blessés à l'ap et usage massif
de gaz lacrymogènes
et procédé à des dizaines d'arrestations
après une intervention de 600 hommes
pour mettre fin à la manifestation
l'enjeu peut paraître dérisoire c'est au
pied de la vieille ville de jérusalem
le site archéologique de la cité de
david les ultra-orthodoxes prétendent
qu'on y profane s'il tire antique le
ministère de l'éducation nationale
responsable des fouilles à ériger un mur
pour protéger le secteur où peuvent se
trouver des tombes mais cela n'a pas
suffi le travail doit se faire sous
protection policière
l'armé principale des ultra orthodoxes
et la prière mais cette fois ils n'ont
pas hésité à avoir recours à la violence
contre la police et les institutions
israéliennes
ils ne reconnaissent pas ils dénoncent
ce qu'ils appellent l'imposture sioniste
ils s'appuient sur leur interprétation
d'un commentaires bibliques interdisant
la renaissance de l'état juif avant la
venue du messie stats
cet homme est l'un de leur ravir ch il
se fait malheureusement ap les ministres
des affaires étrangères de sa secte
hassidique
israël dit il est le seul pays au monde
l'allemande autorise la profanation de
tombes juives le rabbin et ce risque
l'expulsion car il est américain est
accusé d'incitation à la rébellion
36 militants ultra orthodoxes sont
maintenus en détention préventive il ne
possède pas de papiers d'identité
israélien sept d'entre eux sont
américains et pourrait être refoulé la
police se promet d'obtenir contre au
moins des peines de prison ferme
cela suffira-t-il à calmer les esprits
ce n'est pas sûr les ultra-orthodoxes
volpe au contraire profiter de leur
détention et de la répression pour
alerter l'opinion publique
internationale
ils ne sont que quelques milliers en
israël le gros de leurs troupes se
trouve à new york
leur combat est celui d'une stricte
observance qui refuse la modernité dès
qu'elle est incompatible avec la loi
religieuse
c'est ce qu'ils enseignent à leurs
enfants ils ne cesseront la lutte que
lors de la venue du messie
ils font pas ça la police mais ils ont
l'éternité de vente